Salut Romain ça va ?
- Mouais bof...
- Ah oui dis donc qu'est ce qui t'arrives t'es tout pâle ?
Attends assieds toi je vais venir te...
- NON NON !!! Je préfère rester debout.
- Ah les...
Alors avant de commencer j'ai une info pour vous :
Vous avez des hémorroïdes.
Non mais ne paniquez pas
Enlevez votre doigt je vais vous expliquer.
En fait des hémorroïdes tout le monde en a
Parce ce que c'est juste le nom des vaisseaux sanguins qui irriguent l'anus et le rectum.
Elles sont disposées par paquet à l'extérieur au niveau de l'anus
Et aussi à l'intérieur.
Donc on parle d'hémorroïdes internes et externes.
Oui alors je vous vois ricaner.
Non y a pas d'hémorroïdes demi-pensionnaires non...
Grandissez un peu sérieux.
Les hémorroïdes jouent un rôle dans ce que l'on appelle la "continence fine".
Alors la continence fine, c'est comme la charcuterie fine mais dans l'anus.
Non c'est faux.
Ca veut juste dire que les hémorroïdes aident à garder à l'intérieur les selles : le caca
Et les gaz quand il n'est pas opportun de les laisser sortir.
Donc maintenant qu'on sait ce que c'est les hémorroïdes.
Si on parlait un peu de ce qu'on devrait appeler la "maladie hémorroïdaire".
C'est une maladie qui touche aussi bien les hommes que les femmes
Et dont on se plaint généralement entre 40 et 65 ans.
Enfin je dis "on"... je veux dire "les gens" hein. C'était un pronom indéfini, je...
Alors voilà ce qu'il se passe :
Pendant la défécation, c'est à dire pendant que vous crottez
Vos vaisseaux se dilatent.
Oui, alors bon, cela aussi, mais là je vous parle de vos hémorroïdes.
Là où ça devient problématique, c'est quand elles restent dilatées en permanence.
Ca fait un peu comme des varices, mais dans le...
Alors vous allez me dire : "au Diable la varice" !
Et je vais vous répondre : "dans le milieu hospitalier, cette blague est interdite depuis 1987".
Voilà donc pour résumer les hémorroïdes ce sont des vaisseaux normaux
Qui ne posent des problèmes que quand ils restent gonflés en permanence.
Faut pas les juger.
Moi j'aurai voulu être un vaisseau noble, genre une coronaire.
Puis bon je me suis retrouvé au mauvais endroit au mauvais moment
Ca m'a gonflé et j'ai mal tourné.
Bon alors vous n'osez pas me poser la question mais je sais ce que vous voulez vraiment savoir :
A quoi ça ressemble ?
Et bien les hémorroïdes externes
Ca se présente généralement sous la forme de petites boules au niveau de l'anus.
Parfois c'est rouge, parfois ça saigne. Parfois ça ressemble juste à un petit bouton.
Je vous mets pas les photos on est d'accord ?
Les hémorroïdes internes par définition elles sont à l'intérieur
Mais elles peuvent pointer le bout de leur nez à l’extérieur
Quand on pousse ou de façon permanente selon le stade de la maladie.
Okay mais comment on attrape ça ?
Et bien ça ne s'attrape pas.
C'est pas une maladie sexuellement transmissible et c'est pas non plus un infection.
Il y a eu peu d'études très "poussées".
Mais ce serait plutôt un problème circulatoire.
Et y'a des facteurs qui favoriseraient le problème.
Tout ce qui fait monter la pression dans la zone par exemple.
Comme la constipation, la grossesse, l'obésité ou le fait de porter des objets lourds.
Y'a aussi le manque d'exercice physique ou la position assise prolongée.
Ou ce qui irrite la zone comme les médicaments les plats épicés ou l'alcool.
Oui alors un truc avec l'alcool.
Si vous ressentez des douleurs
Vérifiez quand même... C'est pas forcément des hémorroïdes.
Tu te souviens de ce qu'on a fait hier soir toi ?
- Non j'ai un de ces  gueules de bois
- Ah moi c'est pas par là que ça se passe, j'ai une crise d'hémorroïdes mon gars !
- Ah en plus on m'a volé ma montre. Hé j'ai une application pour la retrouver.
Une fois qu'elle est installée, la maladie hémorroïdaire selon les cas
Ca fait mal, ça gratte, ça saigne et ça peut même donner l'impression d'avoir envie de déféquer
Parce qu'elles prennent de la place et que votre corps croit que c'est des matières fécales.
Donc votre corps il déclenche "l'Alerte Caca"
ALERTE CACA ! ALERTE CACA
La plupart du temps les crises s'arrêtent d'elles mêmes mais elles ont tendance à récidiver
Et puis surtout il peut y avoir des complications comme une infection, une hémorragie, une thrombose
C'est à dire un petit caillot.
Ou le prolapsus hémorroïdaire, c'est à dire le fait que les hémorroïdes internes sortent et restent à l'extérieur.
Heureusement, ça se soigne.
Les traitements peuvent être légers : des médicaments.
Un peu moins confortable : des injections dans la zone, des petits élastiques pour ligaturer les hémorroïdes.
Du laser, du froid. Et ?... et ça peut aller jusqu'à l'opération.
Y'a plusieurs formes intermédiaires, mais la plus classique consiste à retirer les hémorroïdes.
Et je veux faire peur à personne, mais je veux pas mentir non plus
Après l'opération, ça pique. Les plaies restent ouvertes et la cicatrisation prend 4 à 6 semaines.
Alors, une plaie ouverte vous voyez le genre...
Une plaie ouverte dans l'anus vous imaginez.
Et une plaie ouverte dans l'anus quand il faut aller crotter :
"And it burns, burns, burns
The ring of fire"
Voilà, maintenant vous savez ce que c'est et comment ça se soigne
Je suis à peu près sûr que vous n'avez pas envie que ça vous arrive.
Ou alors vous aimez les trucs chelou, moi je ne juge pas.
Donc avant de se quitter je vais vous donner 2 ou 3 conseils pour ne pas malmener vos hémorroïdes
Et qu'elles se vengent.
Buvez de l'eau et mangez des fibres pour avoir des jolis petits caca juste mous comme il faut
Pour pas agresser tout ce petit monde.
Quand vous sentez que c'est le moment, ne vous retenez pas.
Allez déposer vos copains à la piscine dès que possible.
Et une fois sur place, ne trainez pas trop.
Vous regarderez DTC sur votre Iphone à un autre moment.
Faites de l'exercice physique régulièrement. Ne serait-ce que marcher 15 / 20 minutes.
C'est bon pour le coeur en plus et pour tout le reste aussi.
Ne restez pas assis pendant des heures sans bouger.
Pensez à vous lever régulièrement pour vous dégourdir les jambes et le... pour vous dégourdir.
Voilà maintenant vous savez quoi faire pour éviter de vous retrouver avec
On se retrouve bientôt pour une nouvelle vidéo.
D'ici là, prenez soin de votre anus et de celui des autres.
Mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous bien.
" De l'anus des autres" ? J'suis fatigué moi.